la atención en el mediterráneo oriental
es uno de los principales temas que los
líderes europeos tienen que tratar
turquía ha enviado barcos de perforación
en aguas disputadas que grecia y chipre
dicen que les pertenecen la unión
europea se ha visto dividida entre un
enfoque de confrontación defendido por
parís y atenas incluyendo sanciones
contra los funcionarios turcos y
llamadas al diálogo impulsadas por
alemania en un intento de forzar a
bruselas a enfrentarse a turquía chipre
ha bloqueada otra crisis
belarús la unión europea condenando la
forma en que las autoridades manejaron
el voto presidencial negándose a
reconocer la reelección de alexander
lukachenko y criticando la represión de
las protestas pero chipre ha bloqueado
los esfuerzos para imponer sanciones
mostrando una vez más lo fácil que puede
ser el bloqueo de la unión europea
los líderes europeos se reúnen mientras
un violento conflicto regional entre
armenia y azerbaiyán se recrudece en la
región de nagorno karabaj como muchas
potencias mundiales el bloque ha pedido
un alto el fuego y diálogo turquía se ha
puesto del lado de azerbaiyán y aumenta
el riesgo de que el conflicto se
intensifique la unión europea hasta
ahora no he encontrado un enfoque unido
para detener a ankara en cuanto a la
crisis de kobe la unión europea tiene
que avanzar en su fondo de estímulo de
750.000 millones de euros los líderes
del bloque siguen divididos sobre las
posibles condiciones necesarias para
acceder a los fondos y sobre si hay que
actualizar el acuerdo ahora que la
pandemia está en aumento en varios de
los estados miembros